[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with susie bonaface
for the moment hoping to be joined later
on by freddie gray and we hope that
they'll be with us both
from now until just before midnight so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages for you now
and after the home secretaries win in
the court case over sending migrants to
rwanda the times has the news of prince
charles that the process is appalling
the daily mail has the same lead story
the eye leads with what it calls a new
plot by tory rebels to oust boris
johnson using the same methods that were
employed by his supporters to remove
theresa may in 2019
meanwhile mr johnson is on the front of
the telegraph with a story about his
plans to unveil a new strategy to grow
food for britain to be announced next
week
the financial times says boris johnson
is to scrap plans for taxes on salt and
sugar in food in order to keep
right-wing mps on his side during his
leadership difficulties
the guardian leads on that too with
critics calling it a missed opportunity
the mirror claims an exclusive with news
that stuart campbell the killer of
school girl danielle jones in 2001 is
asking for parole
even though he's never revealed where
her body is
the express leads with a boom in
staycations as travel misery puts people
off going abroad
the sun has news that prince charles and
camilla are to host an episode of
strictly come dancing from the palace
while the style leads with britney
spears ex-husband gate crashing her
wedding
and reminded that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by susie
boniface columnist at the daily mirror
to take us through the papers you're all
on your loan sim uh tonight but i know
that you're more than more than capable
susie let's um
let's start with the times and um this
very interesting story prince charles
has made comment apparently in private
that uh he's appalled by the
government's rwanda
policy
these kind of stories are always really
fascinating so
constitutionally the royals aren't
supposed to say anything about
government policy they're not supposed
to express an opinion it's it's not what
we have royals for anymore the last time
one of them expressed an opinion we
chopped off his head and the whole the
whole deal with getting them back in
again and we said we won't chop off your
heads anymore so long as you keep your
mouth shut so they're not supposed to do
this however um there are times i am
sure that uh various members of the
royal family have let it be known uh to
make a phrase that they do or don't like
something in particular that's happening
in public i'm pretty certain i can
remember a long time ago the queen uh
was said to have been less than chuffed
with some of margaret thatcher's social
policies and perhaps although those
things may be true they may genuinely
not like or do like a particular policy
the fact that it comes out is the
interesting thing because the royal
family don't don't sit there and just
enough gas at the bus stop and get
overheard by other people they're
surrounded by their employees and
they're surrounded by friends who are
their friends because they don't talk so
if we have heard something they have
genuinely said
then someone somewhere
in that chain
wants us to know that they don't like or
do like this particular policy so
there's there's always loads of thinking
around corners to do the royal story
like this as to how it came out and who
really is the sort of the controlling
mind behind it if you like and do you
think it might be the the prince himself
that wants us to know
i don't think it will do an awful lot of
damage to the prince of wales
to be mostly in tune with public opinion
in the uk which is pretty much against
the rwanda policy as a broad brushstroke
um it could also perhaps help those in
government if it is known that um
they're being you know contested somehow
by the privileged elite um because those
you know the people the cultural war
that we're fighting here with the rwanda
policy is is the government talking to
the pro-brexit white working class on
the one hand and sort of the royals and
trying to put the liberals and the elite
and the woke and and all the other
people on the other side and have this
big argument about rwanda and so it may
suit some people in government to say
well look we're being held back there's
the lawyers on the one hand there's
prince of wales on the other sticking
his nose in how dary you know so it's
it's the kind of thing that just
spreads all this out a bit further and
and sort of um
[Music]
it can make both sides positive or
negative put it that way it can help
both sides to have this kind of thing
come out um but
it's not probably going to help
the general sort of you know the story
of the nation the conversation that we
need to have about the rwanda policy and
asylum seekers and so on he's not
assisting that at all because it will
just come down to an emotional response
do we or don't we agree with prince
charles that we don't actually have a
proper discussion either about the
constitution or about asylum seekers let
us bring freddie gray in now who joins
us uh good to see you freddie
susie's cheering there because you can
take some of them
my invoice has been cut in half
freddie as you probably heard some of uh
what we've been talking about um the
times we're looking at the times at the
moment and it's also in on the front of
the daily mail but prince charles
commenting um in private but being
quoted by an unnamed source that he's
finding the whole rwanda policy uh
appalling what's interesting though is
that clarence house
haven't denied that he's opposed to the
policy but they've insisted that he
hasn't tried to influence the government
well this is what uh a lot of royal
enthusiasts have dreaded for a long time
um about uh as her majesty sort of moves
into
full retirement and prince charles takes
over more fully that we're going to get
these stories more and more and he
it seems like clarence house under his
direction
uh does cultivate does get involved and
the monarchy under him will be
more political more involved in stories
and i think that's a recipe for disaster
for the royal family because um the rest
wrongs this story aside um the reason
the queen was such a big success has
been such a big success
is because she has successfully stayed
out of politics prince charles seems
unable to do that um and so i think
we'll see a lot more of this um
in in the years to come and it won't be
good for the monarchy
although in a a documentary the one
marking his 70th birthday in 2018 he
said he would no longer make public
interventions on uh subjects once he was
cling declaring i'm not that stupid um
so in the the meantime we find that he's
traveling to kigali for the heads of
government meeting um
it is an embarrassing situation for him
and that's probably why speaking out now
although boris johnson wanted this
flight to go ahead before that very
heads of government meeting takes place
in kigali susie
yeah and the fundamental issue there
what perhaps he didn't kind of
appreciate that when he was given that
interview at the age of 70 is that he's
taking on the role of being a king so
he's taking on lots of the
constitutional duties of the head of
state
and
therefore is not able to to express
these opinions publicly
and yet
you know uh they he still has that
hinterland as freddie said we do still
know this about him um but we also know
for example the head of state has also
said something not million miles away it
was only national holocaust memorial day
and not long ago and there was a
luncheon for survivors of genocides uh
rwanda bosnia and uh the world war ii
genocide and the queen sent them all um
a letter and said thank you for coming
to my country and enriching it and thank
me you know we're glad you made us your
home that's not quite the same political
statement saying the rwanda policies
appalling but it is very definitely
um
showing that the royal family has
perhaps a slightly different attitude
towards asylum seekers than some of
boris johnson's core voters do and
perhaps that's linked to the fact that
prince philip was himself an asylum
seeker
interesting uh
analysis there let us move on to a
different story now the ft weekend uh
and this story on the front page
suggesting that the government boris
johnson and his government are going to
drop the recommendation of a sugar and
salt tax
freddie
well there's a lot of talk uh in tourism
circles about how boris johnson is going
to
uh win back the the free market right of
the party the
uh
the
bid of the party that was very
disappointed by lockdowns uh very
disappointed about the way that
government spending has grown
uh is not so keen on protecting the nhs
as the sort of johnson factions in the
party
and so this story i think speaks to
an attempt by number 10 to appease those
uh if you like rabid free marketeers uh
in the party who aren't happy
uh with a lot of the more
um
high tax uh anti-business policies that
this administration pursued so i think
this story speaks to that
yeah suggesting that um this latest
example of the johnson government
backing away from policies perceived as
unconservative or anti-business uh
meanwhile susie the guardian is
suggesting that it's a a huge missed
opportunity
yeah and i think we're going to see more
of this as the the next sort of months
and maybe a year or so unfolds because
we've got a prime minister now who
whatever you think of him is is weakened
in his position within the party
um i was in his office seeing him on
wednesday with a group of nuclear test
veterans uh asking him to deliver
justice and recognition for them uh with
the mirror and i very much doubt we
would probably have been in that room if
his position was not as weak as it is
now he's in he's in that sort of spot
where he really has to try to make as
many friends on all sides as possible so
we will see
policies which were previously promised
dropped because of pressure and we will
see policies that have previously been
dropped being reinvigorated again
because of pressure um sometimes when
you have a weak leader it means that
people that around them that are a bit
stronger perhaps can sort of you know
horse trade and and get some things done
the way they want them move the leader
in their direction other times it means
that the leader just has to try to
please everybody in all directions at
once and ends up pleasing nobody
where where this will or will not work
is whether the prime minister's six and
his team are successful in choosing the
right policies to give way on uh and the
right things to do to to buy those
favors back and whether or not that
strengthens his government to continue
in the long term
uh i'm going to move on because of time
freddie to the express um and the surge
in staycations that
apparently is happening rush for last
minute staycation bookings because of
flight misery international travel is
not looking so attractive at the moment
well i mean i know i'm not going
anywhere this summer
i fully set on the isle of wight is our
family destination
uh and a lot of people i know have made
the same decision they've decided to
cancel plans to go abroad it's just not
worth it the airports are chaotic the
airlines have not gotten their act
sorted um and it shambles at all ends
and the government seems to think you
know maybe bringing in the army
uh might sort it out that seems to be
the government solution to
any uh administrative problem or
legislative infrastructure problem is to
talk about bringing the army
um
they haven't got a handle on it it's a
real problem it's going to be a problem
of the summer
um
and so that's why a lot of people are
staying
within these
within these borders but susie for the
the travel industry i mean this is a
major headache they've just started
opening up i mean it's the first time
people are thinking about
real travel international travel
following the pandemic um this is really
bad news for them
yeah so some people of course would have
booked trips which got postponed and
rolled over and rolled over and they
finally now are you know coming into
into being and they can't get cancelled
anymore and repay your insurance and
stuff like that and then it becomes
impossible to actually then actually
take the holiday the same time they
don't have enough staff back in the
travel companies because they busily
fired everybody far too much enthusiasm
during the pandemic
and on top of that we've got sudden
massive hikes in the cost of fuel so uh
the costs of these things are going up
as well freddie's going to the isle of
wight i haven't been since i was a kid
because the cost of getting there is so
extortionate so i'm going to stop in
dorset
but again that was a that was a i can't
get across the river uh that was the sea
it's because the you know the um
the business of of going on holiday and
having this huge production especially
when you have a young family say going
the idea of going through an airport
when you have small children and maybe
potentially being stuck in it for hours
at a time
is so unbearably painful that um many
many people are going to be trying to do
something else
hopefully that will mean that some of
the cost of holidaying at home comes
down as well particularly the early
white ferry please anyone's listening
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me susie boniface and
freddie gray welcome back um let us have
a look at the daily telegraph um and
this is a sounds like a warning from the
education secretary nadine zahawi that
schools shouldn't use the rail strikes
as a an excuse to return to remote
learning
freddie
well this is another theme that's been
going on around these strikes is a sense
in the government
uh that not just schools but um other
parts of the government particularly the
civil service again
uh are just finding more and more
excuses to do uh remote working and and
i think this is going to be a theme for
this administration
uh in the year ahead it's a sort of war
on
uh remote working a war on stay-at-home
culture
but it's one they've got to wage very
carefully because of course
they were uh
the architects of lockdown so i think
you're gonna see this this fight
happening not just with schools um but
across various sectors
although susie uh remote learning for
schools is by far not not an easy option
it's actually probably more difficult
than than teaching in person
it is yeah i teach uh at university of
london and it's definitely more
difficult
so it's by no means a cop house despite
the fact that some people like to say
that it is um but the issue here within
this article really is that the unions
are warning there comes a point you
don't have blanket car ownership in this
country and with fuel prices and
inflation the way it is it's very easy
to get to the point where someone can't
afford to drive their car or has to sell
their car or can't afford to fix their
car
um and so therefore if you can't get the
train to go to work there becomes a
point where what they're calling a
critical mass you just don't have quite
enough teachers to run the school
and when you get to that point the
people who run the school the head
teacher they have to make a decision in
the interest of everybody's safety to
say well we're just not going to be able
to open the school today
and that would be the same in any walk
of life you know if you wanted to go to
the supermarket and the manager of the
supermarket found that only two percent
of his staff are coming in that day he
can't really safely operate the
supermarket because they could get
swamped by people coming in and just
walking off with stuff on the shelves
that bother to go through the tills so
the supermarket would close so you this
is the problem with the rail strike
as soon as the the if your response to a
strike is to blame the strikers for
daring to do it then your response to
the effects of all the strike that are
going to grow around it has to be to
blame those or blame the schools for
closing blameless the rain for falling
blame this for not going the way i
wanted it to the fundamental issue why
we're going to a strike is because the
negotiations between the government and
the unions have completely failed and
that the two sides have stopped speaking
and if you want to avoid all these
consequences for schools and everything
else the thing to do is to talk
the strikes may still not go ahead
although that looks unlikely but parents
are having uh contingency plans planning
for their children to stay with friends
who live close to school to make sure
they can travel in for gcses and a
levels which is a very important final
story uh freddie this is in the express
uh apparently the perfect formula for g
and t what can you tell us about that
well uh i'm not a great enthusiast of
gentiles particularly uh drinking them
out uh if you're in a pub or whatever
mainly because if you can see in the
picture there those types of glasses i
hate
those glasses i don't know why i have
such stronger versions of them but
people sort of you drown
your gin and tonic in enormous amounts
of tonic and it then it goes flat by the
time you get to the end
so i'm not a big fan i like a small
uh the huge amount of ice it's um by the
end it sort of it doesn't taste of
anything
uh and i think the gin craze has been
going on for too long i think it's time
we found another spirit uh to wreck our
livers with
susie
what is the perfect formula though or
does it not actually give it well i
agree with freddie the perfect formula
is not to have one of these stupid
glasses the size of a soup bowl and fill
it full of ice which by the way should
not cost a thousand pounds for a glass
despite what
some pubs will charge you for but the
formula here for a perfect giant tonic
they say is yeah you have to pour it at
a certain temperature you don't stir it
too much because you lose the fizz in
your tonic uh but the really
offensive thing i find here and i i like
it and sonic okay i'm quite happy with
gin quite happy with tonic i like it in
a nice reasonable glass of five o'clock
in the evening because that civilized
human being what i don't like isn't here
they're saying that the only way to
really appreciate the complex flavors in
gin is that you don't put a lemon or a
lime in it you should be adding mango
and pine they say which i think i'm
sorry that's i want to call the police
there's something wrong with that
somebody somebody somebody call the gin
police uh susie and freddie thank you
very much for taking us through the
papers